[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
es ist juli es ist Sommer es ist heiß in
der bayerischen Landeshauptstadt München
die Sommerferien stehen kurz vor der Tür
nur sieben Tage trennen unzählige Kinder
in München von sechs Wochen Freude und
Freizeit die Stimmung ist also
ausgelassen in der Millionenstadt an
diesem 22 juli 2016 bis
bis David es ein Blutbad anrichtet ein
rassistisches Attentat verübt und neun
Menschen erschießt der rechtsextreme
Anschlag am Olympia-Einkaufszentrum
schockierte München Deutschland und die
ganze Welt wirklich ich weiß nicht wie
es Dir geht aber ich erinnere mich noch
ganz genau wo ich war als die Meldung zu
hören waren überall im Radio online
kommt man Fliesen Schüsse in einer
Großstadt in Deutschland sowas hatte man
bis dahin jetzt nicht besonders häufig
erlebt ja Stefan mir ging's da ganz
genauso ich wohne ja selbst in München
und erinnere mich gut dass die Stadt
nach dem Anschlag wirklich unter Schock
stand die Nachricht hatte sich ziemlich
schnell verbreitet auch wenn man noch
nicht wusste was genau passiert war es
war irgendwie schwer zu begreifen wie
sowas in der eigenen Stadt geschehen
konnte und mir ist auch noch präsent
welche Panik und Unsicherheit kurz nach
den Schüssen herrschte denn dieses
Attentat versetzt in München in einen
Ausnahme Zustand
unser heutiger Fall bei Tatort
Deutschland mein Name ist Mirko Kasimir
und ich bin Stefan Netzeband hallo David
S lebt mit seinen Eltern und seinem
kleinen Bruder in München der 18-Jährige
ist Einzelgänger isoliert und hat wenige
Freunde jahrelang befindet er sich im
psychiatrischer Behandlung in der Schule
wird David S von seinen Mitschülern
gemobbt teilweise sogar körperlich
misshandelt dies waren vor allem
Angehöriger
südosteuropäischer Bevölkerungsgruppen
und daraufhin entwickelt David es einen
Hass Hass auf seine Mitschüler und Hass
auf Personen die sich im Alter und
Aussehen seiner in mobbenden
Schulkameraden ähneln eine ähnliche
Herkunft haben David es macht all diese
Personen verantwortlich für sein Leid
der 18-Jährige der selbst iranische
Wurzeln hat wird zum Rassisten da wird
es beschäftigt sich intensiv mit
Amokläufen und Attentaten er verfasst
eine Art Manifest schreibt darin von
ausländischen Untermenschen die
exekutieren will er ist fasziniert von
dem Rechtsextremisten anders spreewik
der am 22 juli 2011 auf den Tag genau
fünf Jahre vor dem Attentat am OEZ 77
Menschen in Norwegen erschossen und so
plant David es selbst einen
rechtsextremen Anschlag ein Jahr lang
bereitet er sich für diesen vor er spart
Tausende von Euro an die er sich unter
anderem durch Zeitungsaustragen verdient
von seinen Ersparnissen kauft er sich im
Mai 2016 eine Glock und Munition für ca
4000 € im Keller seines Elternhauses
führt David es mit der Waffe Schießübung
durch damit seine Eltern ihn nicht hören
feiert David es auf zeitungsstapeln
außerdem errichte David es einen Fake
Account bei Facebook auf diesem Gebiet
der 18-Jährige vor ein türkische
stämmiges Mädchen zu sein wie die Welt
berichtet am Freitag den 22 juli 2016
postet David es unter diesem Account
vier Aufforderungen an seine
Facebook-Freunde zu McDonald's
am Olympia Einkaufszentrum zu kommen ich
spendiere euch was wenn ihr wollt aber
nicht zu teuer diesen Ort hat David es
nicht zufällig gewählt der 18-Jährige
weiß dass ich am OEZ viele Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund aufhalten werden
und der 18-Jährige will diese Menschen
töten
[Musik]
und so macht sich David S am 22 juli
2016 auf den Weg zu seinem Anschlagsziel
gegen 16 Uhr setzt er sich seinen roten
Rucksack auf gepackt ist dieser mit der
gekauften Glock und Munition außerdem
trägt er ein schwarzes T-Shirt eine
Jeans und schwarze Schuhe und scheinbar
mit seinem Fahrrad fährt der 18-Jährige
Richtung OEZ um kurz nach 16 Uhr trifft
David es noch seinen Freund in der Nähe
des Einkaufszentrums eine Stunde später
um 17 Uhr verabschieden sich die beiden
jungen Männer von David es blutigen Plan
weiß sein Freund überhaupt nichts um
17:08 Uhr betritt David erst die
McDonald's Filiale neben dem Olympia
Einkaufszentrum er wirkt zögerlich mehr
als 40 Minuten lang streift er durch das
Schnellrestaurant bis er seine
Entscheidung trifft David es läuft ins
WC im ersten Stock und holt die Waffe
aus seinem Rucksack
um 17:51 Uhr kommt der zurück in den
Essensbereich und läuft unmittelbar auf
eine Sitznische zu in der eine Gruppe
Jugendliche sitzt als David dort ankommt
fragt er ein 14-jähriges Mädchen der
Gruppe ob es ihr schmecke daraufhin
zückt er seine Waffe und eröffnet
kurzerhand das Feuer
David feuert insgesamt 18 mal auf die
Teenager fünf von ihnen starben ein
13-jähriges Kind kann sich schwer
verletzt über eine notfalltreppe retten
keines der Opfer ist älter als 15 Jahre
gleichzeitig mit den ersten fallenden
Schüssen filmt sich im Außenbereich der
McDonald's Filiale ein paar mit einem
Handy sie lachen zusammen in die Kamera
im Hintergrund hört man David tödliche
Schüsse doch das hier gerade ein
Attentat verübt wird das Verstehen in
diesem Moment nur weniger das ändert
sich jedoch wenige Sekunden später
Videoaufnahmen zeigen wie der Attentäter
aus dem Schnellrestaurant läuft seine
Waffe zückt und das Feuer eröffnet
die Menschen fliehen in alle Richtungen
doch es ist zu spät für einen
17-Jährigen
Davids Kugeln treffen ihn tödlich im
Anschluss erschießt der Attentäter eine
45-jährige Frau und einen 19-jährigen
Mann sogar auf eine Mutter mit drei
Kindern feuert David es schießt ihr in
beide Unterschenkel doch sie kann
gemeinsam mit ihren Kindern fliehen
jetzt läuft David in das Einkaufszentrum
vor einer Rolltreppe erschießt er sein
letztes Opfer einen 20-jährigen Mann der
Attentäter flieht aus dem OEZ rennt in
ein Anliegen des Parkhaus feuert wahllos
auf eine Passanten ohne sie zu treffen
auf dem parkhausdeck wird der 18-Jährige
umher bis ihn ein Anwohner des
gegenüberliegenden Hauses vom Balkon aus
anspricht
geworden
David es feuert auf den Mann auf dem
Balkon aber die Schüssel verfehlen
diesen die Polizei ist inzwischen am
Tatort angekommen ist auf der Suche nach
dem Attentäter ein Polizist entdeckt
David auf dem Parkhausdach schießt auf
ihn aber er verfehlt ihn der neunfache
Mörder rennt vom Parkdeck und versteckt
sich danach in einem anliegenden Haus es
ist jetzt kurz nach 18 Uhr für die
nächsten zwei Stunden wird sich David es
in diesem Wohnhaus versteckt halten und
in der knapp 1,5 Millionen Einwohner
Stadt wird eine Massenpanik ausbrechen
Werbung
wir kriegen ja immer wieder Fragen von
euch rein was ihr denn eigentlich
abgesehen von Podcast zu machen was wir
so privat anstellen ob wir da auch
andere Interessensgebiete haben und ich
sage ganz klar nein in meiner Freizeit
verbringe ich gerne viel Zeit vom
Fernseher irgendwie True Crime Dokus
Krimis etc ich bin ein ganz großer Doku
Fan und Marktes halt wenn ich irgendwie
nach einem stressigen Tag nach Hause
komme oder aus dem Studio gehe und mit
einem Abend irgendwie mich von der
schönen Doku berieseln lasse oder sogar
ich gebe zu auch ein bisschen Trash TV
schauen ja bei mir ist das Problem ein
bisschen dass ich überhaupt gar keine
richtigen Sender habe das heißt ich kann
halt wirklich nur über Apps oder
Mediatheken gucken und wenn ich halt so
richtig Fernsehprogramm will muss ich
halt zu meiner Tante rüber in die
Wohnung bei mir ist das eigentlich ich
habe einen Fernseher zum Glück ja ich
muss nicht zu meiner Tante oder zu
meinem Onkel gehen ich habe einen
Fernseher hast du richtig mit Sendern so
richtig mit seiner bei mir ist halt nur
das Problem dass es dann manchmal Streit
was heißt Streit aber dann gibt's halt
manchmal Diskussion darüber was man denn
gerade sehen will ja der eine möchte
dass der andere das und du geht es hin
und her also der berühmte Streit um die
Fernbedienung genau den könnt ihr euch
aber ersparen denn mit o2 TV könnt ihr
ganz einfach übers Internet schauen da
findet ihr über 130 TV-Sender in HD und
ihr könnt auch bis zu 100 Stunden an
live Sendungen Serien und so weiter
einfach aufnehmen oder Filme anhalten
und später weiterschauen und das gute
ist Mirko ihr müsst euch nicht mehr
prügeln was ihr gucken wollt denn mit o2
TV funktionieren bis zu vier
unterschiedliche Geräte gleichzeitig und
das nicht nur zu Hause sondern auch
unterwegs und das beste TV gibt es jetzt
sogar inklusive Netflix das ist
natürlich ein super Angebot denn ich bin
ja ein riesengroßer Rick und Morty Fan
und auch die Office das sind beides
Serien die bei mir in meiner Netflix
watch schließt ganz ganz oben stehen ich
werde immer in meinem Freundeskreis ein
bisschen gehänselt dass ich noch nie
diese US-Serie shameless gesehen habe
die gab es aber bisher noch nicht auf
Netflix seit dem 1 September haben sie
alle 11 Staffeln drauf geballert und das
sage ich dir am nächsten Wochenende wird
da richtig durchgesucht also falls ihr
die Serie auch noch nicht kennt als es
eure Chance guckt ihr euch mal unbedingt
an also Bucht jetzt o2 TV für günstige
9,99 € im Monat und erhalte 12 Monate
Netflix geschenkt geht dafür einfach auf
o2.de/go2/ Tatort also o2.de/got
/ Tatort TA t o r t und sichert euch mit
o2 TV und Netflix das Beste aus live
Fernsehen und Streaming als Paket alle
Infos und den link zum Angebot den
findet ihr auch in unserem Show Notes
und ihr wisst ja Leute o2 Kendo
Werbung Ende
bevor wir darüber sprechen was in den
nächsten Stunden passiert müssen wir
einmal den Zeitpunkt dieses Sommer 2016
einordnen vier Tage bevor David erst
sein Blutbad anrichtet attackiert ein
Mann fünf Menschen mit einer Axt und
einem Messer in einer Regionalbahn bei
Würzburg es ist ein islamistischer
Anschlag Frankreich acht Tage vor Davids
Attentat ein is-terrorist fährt mit
einem LKW auf eine Promenade in Nizza
und tötet mehr als 80 Menschen
März 2016 vier Monate vor den tödlichen
Schüssen am OEZ zünden islamistische
Attentäter in Belgiens Hauptstadt
Brüssel mehrere Bomben 32 Menschen
werden getötet ich erinnere das auch gut
wir hatten an dem Abend glaube ich eine
befreundete Familie zum Grillen
eingeladen und ich habe diese ganzen
Meldung gesehen und entschieden unsere
Kinder waren damals auch kleiner nach
all dem was du da gerade noch mal
zusammengetragen hast Mirko dass wir an
dem Abend nichts davon erzählen dass man
das wenn keine Ahnung am nächsten Tag wo
er den Nachrichten hört aber sich nicht
auch noch diesen Grillabend quasi mit
Angst irgendwie kaputt macht auf jeden
Fall zurück zum Geschehen das braucht
nur wenige Minuten nachdem die Schüsse
am OEZ fallen bis sich die Meldung
darüber dann eben verbreitet beinahe
gleichzeitig wird die Frage in den Raum
geworfen ob denn das auch wieder ein
Terroranschlag ist vielleicht ein
islamistischer oder ein neonazistischer
in Social Media insbesondere bei Twitter
beginnt das große mutmaßen und auch die
Verbreitung von vielen vielen falschen
Nachrichten um kurz vor 19 Uhr geht bei
der Polizei München ein Notruf ein am
Stachus einer der Hauptplätze München
sein Schüsse gefallen der Platz ist
knapp 6 km vom OEZ und dem Haus in dem
sich David es versteckt hätte entfernt
doch plötzlich behaupten auch Personen
bei Twitter am Stachus vielen jetzt
Schüsse sogar ein Reporter bei NTV
greift diese Meldung auf während einer
Live-Sendung und betont dass dies aber
noch nicht verifiziert sein also die
Meldung über die vermeintlichen Schüsse
am Stachus verbreitet sich wie ein
Lauffeuer plötzlich wird dann aus nicht
verifiziert ein Fakt aus einzelnen
Schüssen werden eine Schießerei und aus
einem oder vielleicht mehreren
Attentäter werden gewisse 3 Täter am
ozet denn Augenzeugen von David S
Attentat Designs zwei Männer in einem
Auto schnell vom Tatort wegfahren also
ein informationskaos waren es Männer die
sich vor tödlichen Schüssen in
Sicherheit gebracht haben waren es mit
Täter eines Attentäter in einer solchen
Ausnahme Situation dann nehmen die
meisten dann pessimistisch auch einfach
das Schlimmste an
wenig später behaupten Personen bei
Twitter wiederum ein Attentäter sei zum
Hauptbahnhof geflüchtet auch dort
entsteht Panik und Hysterie die Münchner
Innenstadt ist wie leer gefegt an jeder
Ecke stehen schwer bewaffnete
Einsatzkräfte ein Polizeihubschrauber
kreist am Himmel auch im Münchner
Hofbräuhaus mitten im Stadtzentrum
bricht eine Massenpanik aus nachdem ein
Mann Shooting Shooting also Schießerei
Schießerei in der Gaststätte schreibt
knapp 1.500 Gäste flüchten aus dem
Restaurant Anwohner Filme die Szene von
gegenüber
schreiende Menschen auf der Flucht vor
vermeintlich fallen den Schüssen mit
Bierkrügen schlagen einige Männer die
Fenster der Gaststätte ein um zu
entkommen
erst um viertel vor acht eine Stunde
nach der ersten Meldung dementiert die
Polizei München die Schüsse am Stachus
doch über den Abend hinweggehen immer
wieder Meldung bei der Polizei über
irgendwelche potenziellen Tatort ein und
während Einsatzkräfte in der Münchner
Innenstadt weitere Notrufen nachgehen
Passanten vor vermeintlich flüchtigen
Tätern in Sicherheit bringen ja sogar
Kaufhäuser evakuieren da versteckt sich
David es weiter im Wohnhaus neben dem
OEZ um 20:26 Uhr also zweieinhalb
Stunden nach seinen tödlichen Schüssen
verlässt der 18-Jährige sein Versteck
und tritt nach draußen vor das Gebäude
hier erwarten den Attentäter bereits
mehrere Polizisten David es erschießt
sich selbst
3 Minuten später veröffentlicht die
Münchner Polizei eine Pressemitteilung
mit dem Titel Terrorverdacht in München
um kurz nach halb neun beinhalten 196
Tweets den Begriff Terror in einer
einzigen Minute und kurz vor halb zehn
sagt die Polizei sie fahren die immer
noch nach bis zu drei Tätern wieso die
Polizei obwohl David zu diesem Zeitpunkt
bereits tot ist weiterhin von bis zu
drei Tätern spricht liegt unter anderem
daran dass die Ermittler natürlich jedem
Hinweis nachgehen müssen vor allem in
einer so extremen Situation muss alles
ganz detailliert geprüft werden und es
war auch nicht direkt klar dass David es
der Attentäter des OEZ war erst um 1:26
Uhr gibt die Polizei offiziell
Entwarnung bei Twitter fünf Stunden
nachdem sich David selbst hingerichtet
hat fast acht Stunden nachdem er sein
tödliches Attentat begonnen hat
die Bilanz an diesem 22 juli 2016 sind
2.300 Einsatzkräfte im Einsatz
4.360 Notrufe gehen bei der Polizei ein
die Ermittler fahren zu 67 Einsatzorten
davon sind 66 Fehlalarme und dann macht
sich ein Gefühl in der Münchner
Innenstadt breit dass man wohl
nachvollziehen kann sich heute aber mit
sieben Jahren Abstand sehr komisch
anfühlt das Gefühl der Erleichterung zum
Glück war es kein Terroranschlag es war
ein Amoklauf es war ja nur ein Amoklauf
sagen die Leute aber in all der Hysterie
geht an diesen 22 juli 2016 das
wichtigste unter 9 Menschen darunter
acht Personen nicht älter als 20 fünf
von ihnen sind nicht einmal volljährig
werden von einem rechtsextremen
Rassisten erschossen
unmittelbar nach dem Attentat beginnt
die Diskussion darüber ob Davids Blutbad
eine rechtsextremistisch motivierte Tat
war eine zum Teil absurde Diskussion die
sich natürlich darum drehte dass er
selber migrantische Wurzeln hatten
Ermittler auf jeden Fall Stufen die
Touch schnell als Racheakt wegen
Mobbings ein obwohl es an David es
rechter Gesinnung ja eigentlich keine
Zweifel geben kann zwei Jahre später
wertet dann selbst das Justizministerium
in Bayern die Tat als extremistische Tat
ein aber das bayerische Innenministerium
zögert und bleibt vorerst bei der
Auffassung es sei eben ein Amoklauf
gewesen kein richteranschlag neben
dieser Debatte finden im selben Jahr
auch zwei Prozesse statt die mit dem OEZ
Anschlag Zusammenhängen
der Verkäufer von David Waffe und der
Betreiber der Darknet Plattform auf der
david ist diese erfahrt stehen vor
Gericht die beiden Männer werden zu
jeweils sieben und sechs Jahren Haft
verurteilt im Oktober 2019 19 also mehr
als drei Jahre nach dem Attentat stuft
dann das Innenministerium den Anschlag
als rechtsextreme Tat ein auch das LKA
ändert in seinem Abschlussbericht die
Bewertung der Tatmotive als politische
motiviert es ist ein schwacher Trost für
die Hinterbliebenen das wie von Mirko
erwähnt die beiden Beteiligten an dem
Waffengeschäft in Haft sind außerdem
beenden die Behörden die Verharmlosung
von David es tat die in ihre Angehörigen
so gewaltvoll genommen hat denn keiner
von David opfern musste sterben weil sie
in der Schule gemobbt hätten oder für
sein Leid verantwortlich waren keines
der neuen Opfer kannte David es
überhaupt jeder seiner neuen Opfer
musste sterben weil sie
Einwandererkinder waren oder eben selbst
Einwanderer somit reizt sich dieser 22
juli 2016 in eine traurige Liste von
Rechtsextremen Attentaten in Deutschland
ein mit Halle mit Hanau mit den NSU
Morgen und zu vielen weiteren
das war unsere heutige Folge von Tatort
Deutschland die Initiative München
erinnern kämpft dafür den Anschlag am
OEZ in Erinnerung zu behalten auf der
Website ist ein Spendenkonto dafür
eingerichtet die Informationen dafür
findet ihr in den Show Notes wir haben
mit Quellen des LKA und der
Staatsanwaltschaft München unsere
eigenen Berichterstattung und zdf-info
gearbeitet außerdem nutzten wir die sehr
detaillierte Recherche der SZ über die
entstandene Massenpanik in der Münchner
Innenstadt
Lilly von der Osten Postproduktion Wake
world Studios München vielen Dank dass
ihr mit dabei wart wir freuen uns wenn
ihr auch beim nächsten Mal wieder mit
einschaltet euer Mirko und euer Stefan